[Music]
Nicole Kidman almost never talks about
her marriage to Tom Cruise but she is
opening up to New York Magazine and
light of the me to of movement saying
quote it definitely wasn't power for me
it was protection I'm married for love
but being married to an extremely
powerful man kept me from being sexually
harassed
Nicole says that when the marriage ended
though it was almost like she had to
grow up interesting interesting find the
comb on meanwhile another star learning
to move on John Cena he's single again
with a new book and a new look that's
got everybody talking I got asked about
the hair because a lot of talk about
your hair
yeah everybody hates it my hair was
something I've ever been very insecure
about and now I'm able to face that
insecurity so like yeah Internet
so John's taking the criticism in stride
but his new do is actually for a role in
the upcoming Jackie Chan action flick
project extraction he's been filming in
China for the past five months but took
a break to do something close to his
heart
I was with the 41 year old as he debuted
his first ever kids book elbow grease to
a crowd of 500 mostly schoolchildren at
the Library of Congress in DC the theme
of never giving up he's even in the
trucks name as elbow grease and one
inquisitive boy couldn't contain his
curiosity over John's current
relationship status back in April he and
Nikki Bella called off their engagement
just weeks before their wedding are you
still a Brie Bella I think you're a
little bit confused
you see Brie Bella is married to Daniel
Bryan so the answer is no do we have
another question brie is Nicky's twin
sister what are you doing you get a
question like that from one of the kids
well the child's question was genuine
and honestly answered it honestly
are you dating now with the longer hair
arm he's a busy man keeping busy that
information I'm gonna keep with me the
you
[Applause]
[Music]